key question i think we gotta we were
asking everybody here let's ask the
audience as well folks what did you
weigh when you were born okay very very
important question because
we're about to reveal
what adam weighed when he was born he
just called his mom right now okay
and we're about to reveal what kai was
born what uh weight and what i weighed
okay
so i say we start off first with k let's
go with you first on what you weighed
when you were born adam your weight when
you were born your mom just said what my
mom said dear adam
six pound eight ounce baby adam
six pounds eight ounces yeah just like
uh
ricky bobby were you were you born on
time were you a fully full term 40 weeks
do you know or no i was a full full-on
baby still haven't grown up yet there it
is check this out you guys ready that
aspect has no idea let me let me tell
you a few people that just put two
kilograms eight pounds eight pounds nine
pounds t nick big boy
lloyd gonzalez sent seven point two four
pounds d28x was 10 pounds aaron kalindo
was 50 pounds okay
so we have george nine pounds we have a
bunch of big babies here by the way okay
a bunch of ten pounders eleven pounders
seven pounders six pounders kai what was
your weight i was nine pounds 9.2 pounds
9.2 pounds yep and i was a 10.2 pound
baby in iran that's the biggest baby in
iran that's got to be the big baby
that's one of the biggest babies in iran
10.2 well i i have a reason why you
could be holding a guinness world record
without knowing it
there might be a reason why you're so
big people don't know if they're six
four you got about
1500 vitamins in a case right here that
you do every morning so one time one
time i was given a guy asked me a
question recently that i had to tease
him about it i was standing next to my
dad the picture with me and the sons did
you see me and the kids i'm standing
with my dad and my boys and you know i'm
taller than my dad
yeah so this guy asked how did you get
so tall okay
it reminded me of a story when i was 25
i was giving a uh a speech to an
audience of 30 or 40 people
and this lady in her early 70s comes up
to me afterwards she says
sir i've met a lot of middle easterns
and armenians but i've never met
somebody with big features like you big
feet she says why are you so big and her
husband was right next to her and i said
ma'am
in the assyrian and armenian culture i
was breastfed till 18.
so she looks get out of here she says
really i did not know that her husband
says honey he's teasing you there's no
way he was breast ventilated
but she pooped me tell me you kept the
joke right
the guys around me were cracking up she
left that was the talk of town the fact
that pat was breastfed till 18. anyways
but i was not breastfeeding i was 16. so
[Laughter]
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]